this video is brought to you by wren
what's up guys michael here and today
we're looking at the hipster king of
modern american cinema
wes anderson whether he's working with
stop-motion canines precocious high
schoolers or
melancholy oceanographers wes anderson's
films are immediately recognizable for
their colorful style
deadpan humor and whimsical tone does it
concern you that your daughter's just
run away from home and that's created a
pretty fierce divide and opinion over
whether he is a
brilliant artist with a singular vision
or a one-note cinematic poser
so are his films just a pretentious
assortment of pastel colors and bill
murray appearances
or is there something more profound
going on why would a review make the
point of saying someone's not a genius
you think i'm especially not a genius
i don't you didn't even have to think
about it did you
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
on wes anderson deep
or dumb and as always spoilers ahead
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this video sponsor
ren now i don't know about you guys but
the constant bad news about climate
change
sucks and the worst part is i feel like
there's nothing i can do about it and
this is where ren comes in ren is a
website that helps you calculate your
carbon footprint and then shows you how
you can offset
your footprint by funding projects that
do things like plant trees
and protect rainforests rather than just
feeling bad about the climate crisis
with ren
you can actually do something about it
all without having to spend all day
outside getting sweaty and dirty while
planting trees
all you have to do is answer a few
questions about your lifestyle
and wren will calculate your carbon
footprint and help you reduce it now as
much as i've tried
no one can reduce their carbon footprint
to zero but you can offset what you have
left after reducing it on your own
because you're already trying to reduce
your carbon footprint on your own
right once you sign up to make a monthly
contribution that will be used to offset
your carbon footprint
you'll receive monthly updates from the
projects you support they'll actually
send you pictures of trees that you
planted
so you can see what your money was spent
on and i mean who doesn't want pictures
of beautiful trees showing up in their
inbox
seriously slide into my dms trees we all
know it's going to take a lot of work to
slow down the climate crisis
so why not start today we've partnered
with wren to protect
five extra acres of rainforest for the
first 100 people who sign up
using our referral link so go to
www.ren.co
join slash wisecrack to join us in
saving the rainforest and fighting the
climate crisis
that's ren dot co slash join slash
wisecrack
and now back to the show now before we
can pass judgment on your favorite tree
man
we should look at some hallmarks of his
style visually speaking wes anderson is
one of the most
instantly recognizable directors in the
business his movies are comprised almost
entirely of flattened images shot via
mostly flat camera movements
allowing each scene to play out like a
series of pages from a picture book
this aesthetic is enhanced by a
meticulous attention to production and
costume design that accounts for
every detail on the screen with a big
emphasis
on symmetry he also tends to make use of
a limited but
vibrant color palette matching each
character's wardrobe to their
environment in a way that removes any
impression of realism
this adds to the sense that we're sort
of watching a children's book come to
life
only filled with smoking sex and
prescription drugs and
sibling kissing did you say you're on
mescaline
i did indeed very much so
between the handcrafted look of the sets
and the flatness of the composition
anderson's style works to make the
movie's whole world feel kind of staged
and he often literalizes this idea by
framing his stories as books or plays
anderson singular's style has brought
him plenty of acclaim
and adoration but for those who don't
find it so charming it's easy to deride
him as a classic case of style over
substance
especially when taking into account his
other trademarks the type of comedy
found in anderson's films is uniformly
deadman
with characters delivering ridiculous
lines and the most unaffected monotone
you're gonna steal his stuff
no we'll get it back to him and
juxtaposing their serious attitudes with
the most
absurd settings she was dynamite in the
sack by the way
she was 84. let me show you stuff i've
had to hold it
between this brand of rye humor the
constant fetishization of retro objects
and the general sense of whimsy it's
easy to call anderson a hipster
filmmaker
and you know it doesn't exactly help
that the dude himself dresses like this
it's not just about the individual
stylistic choices he makes either but
their cumulative effect
he uses all these signature elements to
create an emotional distance between the
audience and the film
and some critics take this ironic
detachment as proof
that there's nothing really going on
beneath the film's pretty surfaces
but this disconnect is actually the
whole point because beneath the bright
tones and cheerful rock songs
all of anderson's films are connected by
an underlying thematic sense
of loss and loneliness see anderson
chooses to tell stories about
outsiders why don't you like me
why should i nobody else does his
collections of orphans and oddballs are
united in the fact that they don't seem
to fit in
anywhere not at home at school or even
within their own families
and yet the world around them is always
so perfectly composed
a place for everything and everything in
its right place
as a result these very out of place
outcasts stick out even more
what's more anderson uses his trademark
deadpan comedy strategically to further
the sense of outsiderness
you filthy goddamn pogba fascist [ __ ]
beyond just giving great actors funny
lines to read
now i'm gonna go hunt down that shark or
whatever it is
and hopefully kill it
i don't know how yet maybe dynamite the
actors monotone delivery
and impassive facial expressions give
the characters a zoned out
air like they're walking through life in
a fugue state often with the help of
some indian cough syrup or
other chemical enhancements anderson's
comedic style is sort of the inverse of
the
mcu's trademark quippiness rather than
making light-hearted jokes in the face
of grave danger
then you have seen ragnarok the fall of
asgard
the great prophecy hang on hang on
let me back around shortly anderson's
heroes speak with
absolute seriousness no matter how
absurd their situation gets
i notice you're a fencing team i'm gonna
try
my hardest to start one up for you guys
the scenario may be funny but the
characters
aren't in on the joke errol to suicide
now
is it dark of course it's dark it's a
suicide now
externally most of anderson's characters
enjoy lives of material
comfort and success and this is
complemented by their rich
vibrant costumes but beneath the
fabulous attire
these people are plagued by a shared
sense of emptiness
what's more their emotional state is
mirrored by the world around them
a world that is uniformly pretty but in
an artificial unlived in way
and that's true whether we're talking
about mr fox's stop-motion treehouse or
the tenenbaum's primary colored mansion
they all seem more like
luxurious doll houses rather than places
containing the messy lives and emotions
of real people
and so the characters invariably remain
emotionally isolated from the fairy tale
world around them
and when you understand this sense of
underlying melancholy as the thematic
through line of anderson's work
his whimsical style becomes a lot more
meaningful take his trademark shots in
which the exterior of a building is
lifted away
to reveal a cross-section of the rooms
inside literalizing the idea of the set
as a
living dollhouse it's more than a cute
visual flourish
each of these shoebox dioramas as they
have been called is curated with the
utmost care and warmth with the camera
calling attention to specific objects
and minor details
it's the sort of loving display you
might get from a collector or a person
fondly examining the objects of their
childhood
doll houses dioramas and keepsakes all
provide us with a means to preserve the
past
paralyzing it so that we can put it on
display and that is exactly the problem
that most of anderson's protagonists
face
each is trapped inside the paralyzed
frames of their own emotional past
unable to move forward or accept their
loss of innocence
for example the tenenbaum siblings are
all gifted kids whose childhoods were
cut short by their success
and whose lives stopped making sense
once they were no longer child prodigies
so it makes sense that as adults chaz
duplicates himself through his twin sons
while margot maintains a teenage
rebellion against parents that have long
since
stopped caring both are desperate
attempts to return to an idealized
family life that for them
never really existed i always wanted to
be a tenant bomb you know
me too and similarly in the darjeeling
limited
the whitman brothers are struggling with
the loss of their father the
disappearance of their mother
i spoke to your mother she's not coming
she didn't get on the plane
and the general deterioration of their
brotherly bonds
their journey across india is really
about recapturing their childhood though
it's also a great opportunity to get
laid in train bathrooms and buy snakes
yes the past happened but it's over
isn't it not for us
even this slightly older and more
settled protagonists like mr fox and
steve zizu
are tethered to the past both of them
are marooned in midlife crises
trying to recapture their daring days as
reckless young men
rather than respected patriarchs mr
fox's crisis even leads to him getting
his tail blown off
an emasculation metaphor that would make
freud blush tales don't grow back
i'm going to be tailless for the rest of
my life and the grand budapest hotel
ties this idea into the arc of history
at large it's framed as a storybook in
which zero reminisces about the hotel's
heyday
and its fall from grace throughout the
concierge longs for a more
civilized past as do those around him
you see there are still
faint glimmers of civilization left in
this barbaric slaughterhouse that was
once known as humanity
indeed that's what we provide in our own
modest humble
insignificant you know
the immediate contrast between the
luxurious colors of the hotel in its
prime
and its drab present-day existence
visually communicates the backwards
yearning that plagues basically all of
anderson's heroes
in each case this yearning is less for a
specific time and place
and more for the sense of innocence
decency and adventure
that it represents a world that feels
the way that it looks
a world that outside the confines of a
west anderson movie screen
can never really exist but anderson
films don't allow us to simply bask in
nostalgic color coordinated scenes
because his bright storybook tales are
unfailingly interrupted
by moments of sudden violence fingers
are severed and tails are blown off
helicopters crash and hapless burglars
are brutalized
in these instances the nostalgic fairy
tale atmosphere is suddenly shattered
interrupted by a violent blast of
reality sometimes this leads to pure
slapstick
but often these eruptions are played
completely straight
delivering some of the film's most
affecting moments especially when the
violence is self-inflicted
when francis whitman removes his
bandages to reveal the scars from his
suicide attempt dork richie tenenbaum
slashes his wrist
the whimsy suddenly goes out the window
untidy gouges and flowing red blood
can't be
woven into the rest of anderson's
orderly aesthetic in these moments the
pain that's been submerged beneath the
deadpan demeanors and vibrant costumes
comes bursting to the surface indeed the
violent moments in the life aquatic with
steve sisu and fantastic mr fox
reveal the full cost of both protagonist
terminal nostalgia
each enjoy a picture-perfect present
which they trade in an attempt to
reclaim part of their past
and those around them pay the price the
tenenbaum family has remained externally
frozen in time
with each member using a different
method to remain emotionally catatonic
but the passing of years still takes its
toll culminating in richie's suicide
attempt
and in the grand budapest hotel history
marches on
crushing the hotel beneath its jackboot
still
gustav and zero endure heavy casualties
in their battle to keep the building
spirit alive
in anderson's films it seems that no one
is immune to the passage of time
no matter how meticulously they try to
preserve the past
in fact the only way anderson's heroes
can ever find
peace is by finally abandoning the past
that they cling to
and the keepsakes they obsess over take
the whitman's they spend their whole
journey arguing over possessions
especially those inherited from their
father like the monogram suitcases they
look
everywhere we learn via flashback that
they were even late for his funeral
because they were so determined to drive
his car there tell them we'll be there
in five minutes
they instill all these objects with a
kind of totemic power
taking them as a proof of their father's
love their own sense of belonging
and a connection to their younger selves
but those days of yore
are long gone and these characters have
to accept that
which they finally do at the end in a
triumphant scene where they
literally let go of their baggage the
metaphor is somehow as
compelling as it is annoying that's fact
i'm gonna make it
no matter what ridiculous scenarios
their story takes them through
pretty much all of anderson's heroes go
through the same grieving process
culminating with them finally learning
to just let go
mr fox accepts the loss of his tale and
his youthful vitality
embracing a new chapter in his family's
life sally and sam returned to real life
with the warm memory of their days in
the moonrise kingdom to steady their
resolve
each of the tendon bombs managed to move
on from their frozen state with chaz
letting his kids run a little freer
eli checking into rehab richie finally
confessing his love for margot
and margot turning their whole crazy
family story
into a new play and then there's zero
who initially seems like a ghost
haunting the ruins of the once beautiful
hotel
clinging to the bricks and mortar long
after everyone that made it special has
gone
but in his final words he outlines
exactly why each of anderson's heroes
need to just chill out and enjoy the
gorgeous worlds they're in
the hotel i keep for agatha
we were happy here for a little while
there's a japanese term which sometimes
gets used to describe the heart of
anderson's work
mono no aware it means an awareness of
the impermanence of things
and the sense that this is both sad and
sort of beautiful
and it's this feeling that runs through
each of anderson's movies
even the happier endings tend to be
tinged with loss like the death of the
titular royal tenenbaum
the collapse of the moonrise kingdom or
the decay of the grand budapest hotel
because ultimately no matter how much of
ourselves we pour into something or how
diligently we work to preserve it
nothing lasts forever but we can still
be happy where we are
at least for a little while they say our
tree
may never grow back but one day
something will
it's easy to take a glance at one of wes
anderson's fussily arranged frames
and dismiss him out of hand as nothing
but an aging hipster with a solid visual
flair
but his vibrant worlds actually provide
us with vivid depictions of what it is
like
to feel terminally out of place with the
sense of loneliness and loss that comes
with the simple passage of time
and every one of his stylistic quirks is
absolutely vital in evoking this
melancholy
so our verdict is that wes anderson is
in fact
deep but what do you guys think have we
convinced you that there's more to
anderson than means to be spectacled eye
or is he just making fairy tales for
drunk adults let us know in the comments
thanks as always to our patrons for all
your support slay that subscribe button
like it's the jaguar shark who ate your
best friend and don't forget to ring
that bell
and as always thanks for watching later
we good okay
[Music]
do